beaucobeauco d'êup d'êe avec nt.
- Ç- Çme fait a me fait  plus gd
des pldes plsirs.aisirs.
- Yani- Yani, pourquck, pourqu ,
40 ans40 anslus tard plus tarda,
alors alors e les yeque les ye e
entièentière sont re sont urnéss
vers lvers lCOVID-19a COVID-19?
- Vers- Vers'autre p l'autre pd,
c'est c'est rce que parce que a.
l'épidl'épidie de siémie de si,e
du siddu sid n'est pa, n'est p .
Il y aIl y ancore en encore ene0
et 1 met 1 mlions deillions dees
qui mequi meent du surent du sae
dans ldans lmonde.e monde.
- On l- On lublie, h'oublie, hn!
- Enco- Enco aujourdre aujourdua
un milun milon et delion et de s
infectinfectns. Il yions. Il y 8
milliomillio de portns de portr.
Et on Et on it que qsait que qnt
porteuporteudu virusr du virusu,
on l'eon l'e pour tost pour too,
l'épidl'épidie est eémie est eo,
mêmê si... ome si... ola pandéue
si l'asi l'are pandéutre pandéen
peu lepeu leevant, e devant, ec,
d'ailld'aillrs.eurs.
L'aut L'aut chose, re chose, ee
c'est c'est e histoiune histoi,,
une hiune hioire impstoire impt,
extraoextraoinaire, rdinaire, ee
tragiqtragiq, avec tue, avec tts
dizaindizain de milles de millns
que leque leida a fa sida a faee
le virle vir a fait.us a fait.ti
une hiune hioire de stoire de i,
de recde recrche, deherche, deé.
- Oui,- Oui,ous dite vous diteqt
une hiune hioire quistoire qui'e
les aules aues, une tres, une li
n'est n'est s comme pas comme s.
- Non,- Non,lle n'ét elle n'étte
les aules aues parcetres parceue
touchatoucha, au dépit, au dépte
touchatoucha au dépait au dépa s
trètrèparticuls particulrs : les
homosehomoseels, lesxuels, leste
droguedroguepar voies par voien.
Il y aIl y au le dra eu le dra,e
drame,drame,es hémop des hémoplt
c'est c'est e maladiune maladiqt
le sanle san le sexeg, le sexela
mort. mort. s jeunesDes jeunesu,
normalnormalent en pement en pii
mouraimourait dans dent dans d s
vraimevraime terriblnt terribl..
Donc, Donc,l y a eu il y a eu.e
maladimaladilà ae-là até tout  e
une maune madie sociladie societ
pas lepas leindividus individuqt
malademalade qui sons, qui sonm,
c'étaic'étaides commt des commai
l'étail'était. Et çaent. Et çaçu
comme comme , notammça, notammtx
activiactivies, aux stes, aux gs
communcommuntaires, autaires, xs
councommuntaires, autaires, i o,
effecteffectement, qivement, q e
sida csida cme une qomme une qse
et polet polique, etitique, etat
comme comme e questiune questi t
médicomédicocientifi-scientifie.
- Et o- Et ola découn la découe,
cette cette ladie, emaladie, e1,
par unpar unout peti tout petia.
- Oui!- Oui!
- Et o- Et odécouvren découvreee
mystérmystéruse dontieuse dontnt
rien, rien,  fait.en fait.
- Oui,- Oui,ui, exac oui, exacm,
5 juin5 juin981, l'a 1981, l'aee
scientscientique du ifique du dt
effecteffectement univement uncn
dans udans ubulletinn bulletinee
trètrè très, trèspécialis spéci,
des Cedes Ces for nters for seal
américaméricns, oùains, oùn méd,
jeune jeune decin d'médecin d'lt
à Là L Angelesos Angeles "J'ai q
cas bicas birres de zarres de u,
comme.comme. à p.. à p prèeu pr,
la trela treaine, quntaine, quét
normalnormalent en bement en bne
et quiet quint attra ont attra ,
une pnune pnmonie, ueumonie, u e
de pnede pneonie extumonie extê"
Telle Tellent rare,ment rare,',
qu'il qu'il ut commafaut commaee
traitetraitent, le mment, le miC
à Aà Aanta dirtlanta dirtementÇe
trouvetrouveas dans  pas dans  u
coin. coin.  c'est bEt c'est ba.
Ils onIls onle systt le systme e
complcompltementètementcroulé. a
seule seule osqu'ochose qu'orem,
c'est c'est e ce sonque ce soncs
homosehomoseels actixuels acti.t
ce qu'ce qu' peut dion peut di.,
c'est c'est , l'acteça, l'actee.
Et on Et on  parle pne parle p,,
du... du...  virus. du virus.  ,
il y ail y an virus. un virus.ne
pas enpas enre, d'aicore, d'aie,
qu'il qu'il ait un ny ait un nv.
- Et ç- Et çdoit êa doit être ac
pour lpour l médecines médecin t
souvensouvenjeunes. t jeunes.  à
RéjeanRéjeanhomas, p Thomas, p a
cliniqcliniq L'actueue L'actueet
arrivearrivedans sa r dans sa ie
jeunesjeunesatients  patients is
adulteadulte qui étas. qui étane
santé.santé.t qui se et qui seet
avec uavec u maladiene maladiee.
- Et u- Et u maladiene maladieye
personperson ne connne ne connî,
dans ldans lcas de Re cas de Re,
c'est c'est 82, son 1982, son et
arrivearriven disant en disant a
maladimaladides Amére des Amérae
comparcompar Ms pae? Mais pae qt
une maune madie qui,ladie qui,f,
touchatoucha beaucouit beaucoul.
la comla comnauté homunauté hos,
à Nà N York etew York etn Calif.
Et làEt là, ils ét, ils étent d.
des jedes jees qui munes qui mrt
à qà q on avaiui on avai.. on nt
rien frien fre. Et çaire. Et ç r
les méles mécins, c'decins, c'ae
chose chose  trède trè très, tr.
EnsuitEnsuit confrone, confrons,
parce parce e les geque les ge ,
et mouet mouient bearaient beao.
- Parc- Parcqu'il n'e qu'il n'ae
traitetraitent, il nment, il n .
- Il n- Il n avait r'y avait rn.
- Et o- Et ovoit desn voit desés
de cesde cesatients  patients it
un peuun peuomme des comme desis
et quiet quint ce  ont ce saome,
cette cette pèceespèce. ces ta.s
violacviolacs qu'on ées qu'on i.
- Oui,- Oui,'est ça. c'est ça.lt
deux..deux..l y a eu il y a eues
presqupresqutypiquese typiquesu,
au débau déb. Donc, ut. Donc,  e
pneumopneumoe à pnie à pumocysts
carinicarini c'étaiti, c'étaitem
de micde micbes en qrobes en qse
sarcomsarcomde Kapose de Kapos e
de Kapde Kapi, c'étaosi, c'éta r
qu'on qu'on yait danvoyait dancs
régionrégiond'Afriqus d'Afriqu t
un peuun peuxotique, exotique,ua
regardregarddans un é dans un a,
un hôun hôpital depital deew Yoy
avait avait  cinq caeu cinq caas
30 der30 derères nières nées, ts
chez lchez l personnes personn -
supprisuppries ou àmées ou à pe.
Et do Et do, on a cnc, on a c à
qui arqui arvent. Etrivent. Etot
vraimevraime surprennt surprente
fameuxfameuxarcome d sarcome dK.
Mais lMais l, en pluui, en plu t
des tades taes violaches violaee
corps,corps,ur le vi sur le vigi
donnaidonnaiune imagt une imagvt
terrterrib du sidale du sida.
- Oui,- Oui,u sida q du sida q e
momentmomentà une-là unealadie .
Il n'yIl n'y pas bea a pas beaos
parce parce e les geque les ge s
expliqexpliqr ce qu'uer ce qu's.
On cacOn cac la malahe la malae.
- Les - Les ladies vmaladies vés
ou lesou lesnfection infectionts
sexuelsexuelment, colement, coet
aujouraujourhui, ontd'hui, ontoé
appeléappelé les males les mali.
Et danEt danle cas ds le cas ds,
il y ail y ait ça. Ivait ça. Iy.
il y ail y ait une ovait une ore
disaitdisaitéjean Th Réjean That
donné,donné,l y avai il y avaide
malademalade Il y avs. Il y avt:
les pales pares, lesuvres, lesé,
qui avqui avent tranaient tran..
ou lesou lesransfusé transfuséo,
qui euqui eu étaientx, étaientis
d'un ad'un aident. Pccident. Pst
les méles méants malchants malex
qui étqui étent des aient des m,
qui étqui étent des aient des ie
droguedroguepar voies par voien.
Donc, Donc,  y avaitil y avaitex
imagesimagesà. Ma-là. Ma oui, ct
une maune madie qu'oladie qu'oc,
qu'on qu'on ulait pavoulait pa..
Les geLes ge n'allains n'allaite
à là ltélévisia télévisi :on :
"Voil"Voil, j'aià, j'aie sida.""
- Une - Une s entrevdes entrevs,
m'avaim'avaimarquée t marquée ap
à là lpoque, p'époque, pce que i
travaitravaié à Tllé à Tonto, ce
de notde not ancien re ancien i,
Luc HéLuc Hért, doncbert, doncue
premipremire et ère et rnièdern.
- C'ét- C'étt un peuait un peun.
C'est C'est  sarcomele sarcomee,
donc cdonc cst le si'est le si??
J'ai éJ'ai éaté en sclaté en sg.
- Puis- Puisc'était , c'était tt
touchatoucha parce qnt parce q t
trètrèrare de s rare de irvoir
ce gence gen d'entrere d'entree.
- J'ai- J'ai'impress l'impressne
le témle témgnage deoignage deu,
c'est c'est ut-êpeut-êe  pretres
où ooù ovoit, enn voit, enros pa
télévitélévion, le vsion, le va,
de quede queu'un quilqu'un quiéi
dit...dit...n avait  On avait  ,
etc. Metc. Ms en fraais en fraac
c'étaic'étaiune des t une des e,
je penje pen. Et ça se. Et ça éi
aussi,aussi,'ai un s j'ai un sv,
trètrèvif de cs vif de cte image
que çaque ça frappé  a frappé u.
QuelquQuelqun disait'un disait i
le sidle sid" Et il a." Et il pe
chemincheminent de sement de sm.
C'étaiC'étaivraimentt vraiment.é
quelququelquchose d'e chose d'pe
que çaque ça permis  a permis  e
le sidle sidétait aua était auit
aussi aussi  visage un visage m.
- Le c- Le c de Rockas de Rockua
des grdes grdes vedeandes vedeed
mêmê, qui onme, qui onadmis quts
avaienavaienle sida,t le sida,uu
changéchangéa donne  la donne st
donné donné  peu uneun peu uneue
de cetde cet maladiete maladie.
- Tout- Toutà fai à fai Juste..,
1982, 1982, 83, donc1983, donc't
la malla malie des aadie des art
la malla malie des hadie des ho,
la malla malie des uadie des ule
droguedroguepar voies par voien.
C'est C'est e maladiune maladiqr
et madet made Tout-lame Tout-lMt
pas atpas ataper, entraper, ene.
Je simJe simifie un plifie un u.
1985, 1985,uand Roc quand RocHe
qu'il qu'il t... qu'est... qu' ,
et il et il  mourir va mourir  ,
si monsi monouvenir  souvenir tt
un peuun peun choc.  un choc. rk
HudsonHudsonc'est un, c'est unée
d'Holld'Hollood, danywood, dand,
dans ldans l séries es séries l.
C'est C'est image dul'image dué.
De l'hDe l'hme àomme àemme, bo .
Et touEt touà cout à cou il annn
orientoriention sexuation sexul,
et ça,et ça,'est vra c'est vraee
du pladu plard, commcard, commo,
extrêextrêmement imement iortana
montremontreussi, ef aussi, efc,
que quque ququ'un coelqu'un coee
une grune grde vedetande vedet,e
touchétouchéEt ça a . Et ça a up
de gende gen Et je ps. Et je pse
c'est c'est  moment un momentùùt
ça basça basle.cule.
- En 2- En 20, il y 000, il y ue
visagevisageussi qui aussi quioe
beaucobeauco. C'est up. C'est ie
de ce de ce une garçjeune garç n
de 11 de 11 s, qui vans, qui vdr
la disla disiminatiocriminatiodt
victimvictimparce que parce qulr
du VIHdu VIHt qui, u et qui, upe
toute toute  crise qla crise q e
à cà cmoment-le moment-l.à.
- C'es- C'es.. On est... On esàa
conférconférce de Duence de Duaa
premipremire foière foique cet t
médicomédicocientifi-scientifi--
culturcultur est danel est danls
du Suddu Sudet en Af, et en Afq,
qui esqui esparticult particulè.
Et àEt à la céré la cérénie d'o,
je me je me uviens, souviens,  t
une doune doaine de uzaine de ls
de perde pernnes dansonnes danle
de cride criet. Il ycket. Il y t
bonhombonhom, Nkosi me, Nkosi h,
qui a qui a  ans.10 ans.
- We a- We a normal.re normal.
- Avec- Aveca cravat sa cravat i
est...est...t qui fa et qui fa ,
mais vmais viment, qraiment, q t
magnifmagnifue, en dique, en das
sommessommesnous aus, nous aus,s
des bedes beins." Unsoins." Unot
bonhombonhom de 11 ame de 11 a,i
va mouva mour d'aillrir d'aillre
d'aprd'aprs. Maiès. Maic'était t
impresimpresonnant. sionnant.  a
symbolsymbolait, ouiisait, ouile
de l'Ade l'Aique, mafrique, ma n
connaiconnaiait quanssait quanms
une diune diine d'anzaine d'ane,
symbolsymbolait aussisait aussln
peut vpeut vre avec ivre avec  r
le sidle sid et êa  et êe quelqt
êtrêtrun humaie un humaicomme l.
Nous aNous ans des mvons des mns
et deset desambes co jambes coe.
C'est C'est traordinextraordinr.
- Parc- Parcque l'Afe que l'Afqe
momentmomentà, c' là, c't l'apoe
un peuun peuOn voit . On voit ss
de vilde vilges oùlages oùl ne e
des vides villards oeillards od.
Toute Toute  populatla populatne
est déest démée.cimée.
- Quan- Quanje suis d je suis l,
à Dà Dban en 2urban en 20, je sé
aussi aussi  Johanà Johansbourgg
pour vpour vr le sidoir le sid s
dans ldans lconférena conféren,,
mais dmais ds la popans la popa,
et il et il a une jey a une jee,
elle-melle-mme sérême sérositiv,
qui faqui faait de lisait de lcn
communcommuntaire, qautaire, q :
"Si ça"Si çaontinue, continue,la
plus dplus djeunes. e jeunes. u,
il y ail y aes gens  des gens it
diagnodiagnoiqués chstiqués ch t
en Afren Afrue tradiique tradio,
m'explm'expluait queiquait queu,
on mouon mouit, soitrait, soitre
des mades madies de ladies de  e
enfancenfanc soit âe, soit âgé t
le monle mon, puis, de, puis,  ,
il y ail y ait des gvait des gsi
vivaievivaie. Puis, nt. Puis, àt
le mille milu qui esieu qui esf.
Les geLes ge meurentns meurenttt
leurs leurs fants. Lenfants. Lde
des ordes orelins duphelins duit
des mides miions d'ellions d'eas
du siddu sid C'étaita. C'étaitrn
drame drame rrible. terrible. At
l'accl'accs aux ès aux dicament,
en 200en 200 étaient0, étaientr.
- Oui,- Oui,n Afriqu en Afriqu s
qu'en qu'en 96 arriv1996 arrivcx
traitetraitent, la tment, la tt,
qui vaqui vahanger,  changer, a,
la donla don pour cene pour cee.
- Qui - Qui ange la change la ns
gens qgens q ont... ui ont... it
avoir avoir cès accès  la trà l,
qui, equi, egénéral,n général,ea
supporsuppornt bien,tent bien,e,
en groen gro le sidas, le sidaee
chronichronie. Les pque. Les pts
qui onqui onla tritht la trithaa
suivensuivenbien, qut bien, qupa
suivresuivreont une , ont une pe
à pà p prèeu prèsemblabls sembls
qui n'qui n't pas leont pas lei,
c'est c'est and mêquand même in.
Donc, Donc,n a ça e on a ça e1.
C'est C'est mme un mcomme un ma,
en 200en 200 on est 0, on est u.
on n'aon n'aoujours  toujours ss
à cà c médicames médicamts-làen,
il y ail y an slogan un sloganut
ces acces acvistes, tivistes, it
vraimevraime extraornt extraorn:
"Les m"Les micamentsédicamentsos
leorle nor les patd, les patntst
dans ldans lsud." Ce sud." Ca Ç.
- Ç- Çfait pena fait penr un peu
à cà cqui se pe qui se pse en c.
- C'es- C'esexactemet exacteme e
chose.chose.t donc,  Et donc, s,
en 200en 200 disent 0, disent ".
Les méLes mécaments dicaments ir
dans ldans lsud. Lese sud. Lesos
pharmapharmautiques ceutiques ir
leur pleur px." Doncrix." Donce,
les scles scntifiqueientifiqued:
"D'acc"D'accd, ifaord, il fa ça"
Et en Et en 04... Et2004... Etai
spéciaspécia en partl, en partu.
Il y aIl y ane solid une solidié
interninternionale qationale q a
créé lcréé lFonds moe Fonds moie
contrecontree sida,  le sida,  e
et le et le ludisme,paludisme,ur
des mides miiards delliards deor
pouvoipouvoiamener lr amener lte
dans ldans lsud. Et e sud. Et ee
quelququelquchose que chose qus,
Mais çMais ça pris da a pris dx,
quatrequatrens, pour ans, pourue
les méles mécaments dicaments  d
arrivearrive dans lent dans leu.
- Yani- Yani, vous ack, vous azt
cette cette ladie dumaladie duéà
aujouraujourhui, prad'hui, praq.
- Oui.- Oui.
- Donc- Doncqu'est-c, qu'est-cqs
reteneretene Parce qz? Parce q e
s'appes'appee "Le delle "Le dela
parlé,parlé,t "la lu et "la luè.
PourquPourqu "la lumoi "la lumè?
- Bien- Bienla lumi, la lumire,a
lumièlumière qui are qui aorte .
Les geLes ge n'ont jns n'ont jae
dans ldans l années es années ss
au débau déb des annut des annsd
aucun aucun dicamentmédicamente,
rien, rien,  était ton était tj.
la grala grae déprimnde déprim s
gardaigardait l'espoent l'espo é
de se de se ttre. Cbattre. Ca,Çt
quelququelquchose d'e chose d't.
Le fa Le fa aussi qit aussi q t
une maune madie, donladie, donqt
vécue vécue r des grpar des grpr
des endes enmbles desembles dear
des asdes asciationssociationse,
ça, c'ça, c't importest importts
surtousurtou la lumit, la lumiri
la lumla lumère qière qapporte a
sciencscienc Je m'exe. Je m'exs.
Ha! haHa! haha!! ha!
- C'es- C'esimportant important.
- La t- La tthérapierithérapiect
un proun proit de laduit de laée
de la de la ience, cscience, cte
médicamédicant, celument, celuqe
la dla difrence. Cférence. Cst n
médicamédicant qui ament qui ata
découvdécouvt commenert commenft
une enune enme en 19zyme en 19-.
On a tOn a tvaillé pravaillé prr
une moune mocule, pulécule, pu ,
on l'aon l'au, en 19 eu, en 19.a
trithétrithépie, il rapie, il ai
quelququelquchose d'e chose d't,
c'est c'est  3TC, méle 3TC, mécé
à Mà Mtréal, dontréal, deloppé à
MontréMontré, qui esal, qui eseé
aujouraujourhui. Dond'hui. Don ,
la recla recrche sciherche scitt
la recla recrche cliherche cliqt
la difla difrence, cférence, cm,
comme comme est le cc'est le c c
la COVla COV. Donc, ID. Donc, e,
la lumla lumère. ière.  lumièLa,
c'est c'est  lumièla lumière que
la recla recrche sciherche scit,
la recla recrche médherche méda.
- C'es- C'esl'espoirt l'espoir.
- Oui.